hey da sind wir wieder zdf heute live
schön dass ihr auch wieder mit am start
seit ganz kurz jetzt nicht erschrecken
wir spielen kleines spiel miteinander
kennt ihr vielleicht ich habe hier eine
münze in der hand kopf oder zahl ich
sage einfach mal ihr seid kopf und ich
bin zahl mal gucken ob das hier
funktioniert
so ist kopf würde ich sagen habt ihr
gewonnen aber so ein spiel das kann
natürlich nicht immer nur ein battle
sein es kann auch sein dass es einem die
eine oder andere entscheidung auf
einfach mal abnehmen wenn man gar nicht
mehr weiter weiß ich kenne das von mir
selber einfach mal münze werfen sagt hat
man eine entscheidung vielleicht ja auch
bei der frage die gerade viele von euch
vielleicht beschäftigen oder irgendwann
im leben mal beschäftigt hat studium
oder ausbildung was ist besser das ist
heute unser thema und da hören wir nach
und sprechen darüber mit zwei tollen
gesprächspartnerinnen die müssen wir
jetzt gleich glaube ich auch hier schon
mal bei uns sehen da sind sie einmal
klar want it all und elena handwerk
reihe beiden schön dass er heute bei uns
seit
wir sprechen gleich mit ausführlicher
über ihren werdegang jahre hat sich
nämlich für eine ausbildung entschieden
elena für ein studium warum das ganze da
vertiefen will gleich und wenn ihr
fragen an die beiden habt schickt ihr
uns gerne per mail oder auch einfach per
app oder in den chat erkennt das zdf
heute.de
zdf.de vorher aber vielleicht zur
orientierung und auch für uns alle
schauen wir auf die zahlen die heute die
deutsche industrie und handelskammertag
herausgebracht hat das sind zahlen die
zeigen dass es für betriebe noch nie so
schwierig gewesen ist auszubildende zu
finden wie aktuell 43 prozent sagen sie
haben eine offene stelle sie sagen wir
konnten nicht alle unsere stellen
besetzen das sind elf prozent mehr als
2008 10 und was noch dazu kommt dass 36%
aussagen dass sie noch nicht mal eine
einzige bewerbung erhalten haben so was
sind die gründe die jetzt erstmal
angeführt werden zum einen die
demografie zum anderen aber auch die
korona pandemie
was also tun vielleicht kann uns jahre
helfen chiara ihr beide seid
unterschiedliche wege gegangen aber es
scheint auch etwas erteilt bei instagram
euren alltag seit damit auch sehr
erfolgreich und kann vielleicht die
erste frage an dich du schreibst bei
instagram es ist nicht immer leicht auf
dem dach aber ich mache gern in bochum
du bist dachdeckerin aus dem ruhrgebiet
warum hast du dich für diese ausbildung
und diesen beruf entschieden
also es dinge erst los dass ich an der
uni war und danach meinem büro
ausbildung gemacht haben also ganz weit
weg von der baustelle ja und irgendwann
hat es mich einfach so angeht also so
gelangweilt immer nur alles theoretisch
zu machen und weil ich die büro
ausbildung bei uns im betrieb im
dachdeckerbetrieb gemacht habe und dass
da halt sehr praktisch zugeht nur halt
an anderer stelle habe ich mir
irgendwann gedacht es wird
wahrscheinlich mehr spaß machen wenn ich
auch mal selber anfassen kann und dann
habe ich nach den zwei jahren büro
ausbildung angefangen meine dachdecker
ausbildung hin zu machen habe vor allem
jahr meinen gesellenbrief erhalten und
seitdem bin ich weiterhin auf dem dach
und das gefällt mir sehr du hast es
gerade schon angesprochen unser betrieb
vielleicht lässt uns ganz kurz auf dass
es der betrieb seiner eltern welche
rolle haben die vielleicht auch bei
dieser entscheidungsfindung oder dieses
umfeld gespielt
also meine eltern haben mir von anfang
an die freiheit gelassen alles zu machen
was ich will dass er bin ich auch nach
der schule erst mal zur uni gegangen
also ich würde gar nicht in irgendeine
richtung gedrängt ja und dann hat man
halt das glück dass ich irgendwann den
weg wieder zurück gefunden hat und jetzt
die arbeit aber damit hätte auch keiner
gerechnet also ich wollte nicht in
irgendeine richtung gedrängt aber nicht
von meinem vater der selber dachdecker
ist also überhaupt nicht ja aber cool
dass ihr jetzt sozusagen gemeinsam mit
auf dem dach stehen könnt und auch den
betrieb weiterführen könnte lena du hast
gerade eben ein jurastudium an der
cambridge university abgeschlossen
glückwunsch erstmal noch mal von uns
dazu du hast auch da videos von deinem
alltag gezeigt und bis dadurch sozusagen
auch fast als ich nenne es jetzt mal
studiums in florenz lerin bekannt
geworden frage vielleicht auch an dich
war es für dich auch immer klar bio
studium das mache ich und wie hast du es
vielleicht auch geschafft an die
cambridge university zu kommen
nein es war nicht immer klar ich war
auch nicht immer die motiviertes sind
lehrerin aber so ab dass nach dem klasse
kann man so ein bisschen der ehrgeiz
durch weil für mich relativ klar war
dass ich in rechtswissenschaften
studieren möchte und das ist halt eben
was muss man halt studieren und ja
deswegen war dann schon ein update
bereit klar es wird auf jeden fall ein
studium und ich haben mich dann
angestrengt ich wollte sehr gerne
studieren weil ich eben im
internationalen bereich arbeiten möchte
mich das mal gelb dann kann ich das
alles schon direkt auf englisch haben
und haben dann geschaut dass ich relativ
gute note nehmen ob kriege ich auch
stipendien kriegen kann ich habe meine
mutter wäre studium ohne jetzt nicht
finanzierbar gewesen
und ja dafür hab ich mich dann halt
reingehängt in der schule er habe
sprichst es an also doch dann auch ein
schwieriger weg dahin für viele ist ja
auch die frage studium besser als
ausbildung oder studium oder ausbildung
was mach ich da eigentlich eine sehr
schwierige frage ich kenne das von mir
selber aus meinem umfeld gerade nach der
schule da waren einige ganz schön
überfordert können wir vielleicht alle
in unseren momenten vielleicht auch noch
mal die frage an dich hast du das auch
so wahrgenommen und war das für dich
manchmal auch überfordern diese
entscheidungsfindung
also für mich persönlich war es recht ja
das ist natürlich studium bild aber es
wurde wenn hier vor allem an den
gymnasien in deutschland an dem ich war
schon oft irgendwie so angenommen dass
einfach jeder studieren gehen würde der
auf dem gymnasium ist und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass ich einer von meinen
lehrern damals als wir in sicht ab der
neunten klasse waren einfach mal hin
gestellt habe und gesagt halt so
genannten gleich mit chemie unterricht
weiter aber ich möchte euch sagen wenn
ihr eine ausbildung machen wollt wenn es
mein traum ist schlosser zu werden was
er braucht ein studium
lasst euch einen traum ich kaputt machen
und vor allem macht dann das was da für
sinn macht und da musste man sich dann
zum beispiel für so eine bestimmte
prüfung anmelden dass man eben abgehen
kann mit dem realschulabschluss vom
gymnasium weil es eben doch nicht so
automatisch kam und wie ihr lehrer haben
einfach gedacht ja die gdl alle weiter
die oberstufe machen aber dazu studieren
und da wurde eigentlich nicht so richtig
darüber aufgeklärt was meinung nach sehr
schade ist weil es gab schon einige
leute die sich ein bisschen dafür
interessiert haben aber manchmal auch
einfach zu spät gemerkt dass ich das
machen müssen und deswegen bin ich dem
einen der schon sehr dankbar dass sie
sich allein gestellt haben gesagt hey
leute überlegt euch was ihr machen
wollte und wenn es das ist was eine
ausbildung ist dann macht das weil im
endeffekt müsst ihr halt dann der rest
aus lebens diesen beruf wahrscheinlich
auch ausüben
vielen dank dass du das teils kiaka wie
war das bei dir hast du das erlebt auch
in der ganzen entscheidungsfindung
komplett gegenteil ich also ich war auch
am gymnasium und da hat und sich kein
lehrer vor uns gestellt und gesagt es
gibt übrigens noch einen anderen weg aus
der uni also ihr könntet auch eine
ausbildung machen das hat ja keiner
gesagt wir hatten orientierungstage da
waren wir drei tage an der ruhr uni in
bochum konnten da also in die vorlesung
reinschnuppern aber auch wirklich cool
und davor und danach haben wir auch so
mit den lehrern uns zusammengesetzt
verschiedene studiengänge
durchgesprochen alles super aber es hat
halt keiner darauf hingewiesen dass der
ausbildung auch möglich wäre oder
maximal duales studium dass man das mit
der ausbildung verbindet aber handwerk
oder so da warum soll mein abitur machen
wenn man ins handwerk geht das haben
halt damals so alle mir gezeigt das
hättest du dir da vielleicht an unter
einer individuellen position jemanden
gewünscht wie es jetzt vielleicht auch
bei elena war der dann wirklich auch so
mut zugesprochen hätte oder auch andere
perspektiven aufgezeigt hätte
ja auch und das man halt ja fast schon
sowie berufs tagen hat das ich kann das
jetzt wir gehen in hauptschulen und
realschulen wir als betrieb und machen
da so ein bisschen jugendarbeit
versuchen wir so ein bisschen fürs
handwerk zu begeistern zu
ausbildungsmessen und dass man so was am
gymnasium hat auch anbietet und zwar und
dafür auch handwerksbetriebe einlädt
oder andere betriebe muss ja jetzt nicht
unbedingt handwerk seien aber halt nicht
nur komplett den fokus auf uni legt
sondern auch sagt guck mal erweitert
neuer blick fällt man kann auch eine
ausbildung
spannende punkte die ihr beiden uns da
gerade schon mal teilt die er vielleicht
auch zu hause sozusagen bei der
entscheidungsfindung vielleicht noch
helfen kann wonach man auch mal fragen
könnte bevor wir gleich mit euch beiden
weiter sprechen zeigt uns jesko buchs
jetzt erst einmal wie aber der generelle
trend in deutschland ist richtung
studium oder doch richtung aus dem
immer mehr jugendliche zieht es nach
ihrem schulabschluss an die unis 2020
gab es an deutschen hochschulen 490.000
neue studierende im vergleich dazu
begann nur 466.000 menschen eine
ausbildung tendenz sinkt für das
handwerk bleibt dieses ungleichgewicht
nicht ohne folgen nach beginn des
letzten ausbildungsjahres blieben in
deutschland 63.000 stellen unbesetzt
viele betriebe bank bereits jetzt um
ihre zukunft
natürlich sind nicht alle branchen
gleichmäßig betroffen ausbildungsplätze
in medienberufen oder zum tierpfleger
waren besonders gefragt in der
gastronomie und im handwerk blieben
dagegen die meisten stellen frei von 1,3
millionen auszubildenden waren übrigens
fast zwei drittel männer
gegenbeispiele haben wir heute bei uns
in der sendung thiago motto du bist
dachdeckerin aus buchen das haben wir
schon thematisiert das haben wir
angesprochen
nimm uns doch mal vielleicht ein
bisschen mit in den alltag visiten so
ein tag bei dir dann aus
37 geht's bei uns in der firma los da
treffen wir uns alle am hof besprechen
einmal die einsatzlage dann werden die
autos gepackt ja und so ich würde sagen
spätestens 18 uhr ist man dann auf der
baustelle
wir machen um 12 uhr mittagspause eine
halbe stunde und dann haben wir so gegen
15 30 wieder rein und
was dann in der arbeitswelt passiert das
ist ganz unterschiedlich also von
großbaustelle von riesigen neubaugebiet
wo man mehrere häuser nacheinander macht
bis zu kleinst reparatur wo man bei den
kunden einmal schnell aufs dach springen
und gedachten dachziegel wieder nicht
nur ist also alles kann es sein dass er
das ist super vielfältig voll und du
hast es auch angesprochen für dich als
typ menschen einfach passender
vielleicht in dem moment und wenn man
sich dann im vergleich im studium zb den
tag einfach sehr eigenständig
strukturieren muss elena das sicherlich
eine der größten herausforderungen in
seinem studium vielleicht aber auch noch
mal die frage an dich nehmen uns beim
mit in diesen mythos cambridge
university wie war dein alltag wie visa
hat das aus
und der undercut natürlich lernt
erschienen zwischen während der
akademien vor der pandemie das was
gleich geblieben ist ist dass ich früher
sterben ich stehe ja inzwischen vier und
spätestens 6 uhr halt auf und dann eben
auch schneller tief vom schreibtisch und
je nachdem hat man dann halt entweder
online vorlesungen gehabt während der
pandemie oder ist dann tatsächlich noch
zu den vorlesungen gegangen und wir
haben dann auch noch
kleingruppenunterricht und bei mir was
dann immer so dass ich bis so maximal 18
uhr eben sachen für die uni gemacht habe
und danach habe ich quasi einfach ja was
gelesen oder etwas gespielt oder so
also ich stelle fest ihr beide seid auf
jeden fall früher aufstehen und da sehr
hinterher das zu machen wo elena siehst
du vielleicht aber auch für dich so den
größten vorteil in dem studium oder
warum hat er das vielleicht auch was
gebracht
na ja also es war halt eben so dass ich
rechts wissen ich hab nicht machen
wollte und dann gibt es halt nur den weg
als studium aber ich bin auch jemand der
ihn sehr gerne lernt ich mag es eben
auch in der bücherei viel zu sitzen in
bücher nach quellen zu suchen und so
weiter und ich mache das auch dass man
sich viel sein tag selbst gestalten kann
da hat gibt es natürlich immer dann so
die gefahr dass man sich zu viel
freizeit einteilt und am ende mehr glück
ich bin ich hinterher gekommen meine
arbeit aber aus diesen fehlern lernt man
ja auch aber es war halt immer so was
für mich hat es schon so perfekt gepasst
dass es eben auch einfach viel ernst ich
mach das hat auch gerne aber man muss
immer schauen was für einen selber dann
so am besten passt
genau also auch eine feststellung
zwischen euch beiden zwei
unterschiedliche wege aber doch am ende
dann vielleicht in dem moment auch das
beste für jeden einzelnen du hast auch
gerade schon angesprochen elena so den
freiheits aspekt das ist sicherlich
natürlich auch ein grund für viele die
erst mal sagen im studium kann ich auch
meine persönlichkeit weiter entwickeln
und vielleicht auch einer der gründe
warum es der trend dazu hin geht das
viel mehr im moment richtung studium
tendieren und die auszubildenden so an
kleinen daumen erleben was es für gründe
aber vielleicht noch gibt da nimmt uns
sehr jetzt nochmal mit
experten sehen in deutschland einen
hohen akademisierung ausdruck das heißt
den drang eine möglichst hohe bildung zu
erreichen durch den vergleich mit
anderen oecd staaten sei in deutschland
der eindruck entstanden nur wer an die
uni geht habe später eine chance
also ist immer noch so dass viele denken
ein studienabschluss ist eben das
goldene ticket in den arbeitsmarkt ich
habe einen sicheren arbeitsplatz ich
verdiene gut aber so pauschal lässt sich
das eben überhaupt nicht sagen die zahl
der abiturienten hat sich dadurch in den
letzten 20 jahren beinahe verdoppelt
wer früher nach dem schulabschluss eine
ausbildung begann geht nun studieren
mittlerweile studieren gar 55,8 prozent
eines jahrgangs eine änderung ist nicht
in sicht so wird der termin mit dem
handwerker wohl auch in den nächsten
monaten eine geduldprobe bleiben
ich sehe gerade das ihr schon ganz
fleißig hier auch kommentiert und auch
meinungen rein schreibt zum beispiel bei
facebook von isabel bemühen sie sagt
eigentlich auch so ein bisschen ein
punkt ein grund ist das bewusstsein sie
sagt weil schon grundschülern in der
schule vermittelt wird dass das
gymnasium ja vielleicht dann doch die
einzig wahre option ist jahre passt auch
so ein bisschen zu dem aspekt den du
vorhin geschildert das was würdest du
sagen was muss ich tun was muss sich
ändern damit ausbildung damit handwerk
vielleicht auch für junge menschen
einfach wieder attraktiver wird
also ich würde sagen da müssen mit
einigen vorurteilen aufgeräumt werden
die uns die ältere generation so weiter
gibt es der opa der sagt auf dem bau
wird nur geschleppt und
da verdient zunächst also das sind ja
vorurteile die immer noch kursieren
ansonsten muss man halt auch eltern
sagen pass mal auf ich weiß wir wollen
alle dass unser sohn unsere tochter arzt
und und
rechtsanwalt wird aber am ende des tages
muss man auf jedes kind individuell
eingehen und für manche kinder ist hat
die erfüllung einfach schreien zu werden
und das ist auch gut und das ist ja
überhaupt nicht schlecht und wenn man
jetzt nur schreiner wird man kann sich
ja auch da komplett entfalten und
hocharbeiten und vielleicht sogar im
eigenen betrieb gründen das da steht ja
dem arzt auch finanziell fast schon im
gar nichts mehr wenn wir mal ehrlich
sind also die auftragsbücher sind voll
jetzt gerade im handwerk das dolder
boden und das sind halt so sachen dass
man den kindern hat von anfang an nicht
sagt auf den bau gehen und immer ja du
sprichst den oft schlechten in
anführungszeichen schlechten ruf an viel
arbeit schwere körperliche aber das ist
natürlich auch bestandteil aber du sagst
gerade das stimmt eigentlich nicht lasst
uns mit den klischees aufräumen wie
erlebst du es
ja es stimmt natürlich immer gute und
schlechte betriebe aber in guten
bisschen wird darauf geachtet dass zum
beispiel
keine samstagsarbeit gibt keine überall
so überstunden und das ist ja früher war
es gang und gäbe drei stunden länge zu
machen auf der baustelle heute muss man
ja damit
einfach mit der work-life-balance gehen
und sagen okay um 16 uhr fällt der
hammer wir können hier nicht mehr bis 19
uhr irgendwo mal lachen weil dann hat er
auch keiner mehr bock drauf ja solche
punkte dann natürlich dass man anfängt
maschinen zu kaufen die die mitarbeiter
auch körperlich entlassen wenn man es
jetzt zum beispiel vor zwei wochen kran
angeschaffte ist das beste was uns
passieren konnte seitdem müssen wir halt
schwere sachen nicht mehr aufs dach
schleppen in einführung zeichen sondern
können es mit einem kran hochheben und
das sind so kleinigkeiten die man ja den
leuten halt sagen was es ist nicht mehr
so wie früher vor baustelle das hat sich
schon einiges getan
danke dass du es mit uns so teils tel nr
wir müssen natürlich auch trotzdem sagen
oder oder kaká hat auch angesprochen
dass man sich auch in dieser schiene
dann hoch arbeiten kann den meister
machen kann durchaus erfolgreich sein
kann trotzdem ist natürlich auch in
deutschland so das schreibt auch ihr
hier bei uns in auf youtube und in den
facebook kommentaren immer kein dass du
natürlich für bestimmte berufsgruppen
dann einfach das papier in der hand
brauchst den abschluss ich meine gerade
bei dir jurastudium da sind die noten da
ist auch der abschluss ein wichtiger
faktor oder
klar also ohne den abschluss kann man
eben gewisse dinge nicht ausüben scalzo
in deutschland werden
natürlich noch deutscher stellen mit dem
staatsexamen im mauerfall so aber das
hängt davon ab ob man das dann wirklich
auch machen möchte ich glaube es ist
aber auch schwer mit 18 von sicher zu
wissen dass man ein sehr langes studium
machen möchte oder so und das ist
wirklich der berufswunsch bleibt also
träumen können sich natürlich auch
ändern bei jedem was würdest du genau
spannender punkt wichtiger punkt was
würdest du dir da vielleicht auch in
diesem prozess
wünschen was es vielleicht für
hilfestellungen und auch geben könnte
ich glaube es wäre sehr hilfreich wenn
solche praktika so wir hatten uns damals
acht und zwar so ein bogy praktikum das
war auch mal eine woche wo man sich
schon mal ein bisschen berufs
orientieren konnte wenn die
wirklich mal mehr einblick geben würde
und vielleicht auch wenig später
stattfinden würden also eine elf
zwölften klasse und man da vielleicht
auch mal einen monat oder so oder auch
länger noch ist dass man vielleicht auch
so ein sommerferienprogramm so anbietet
dass man auch wenn es mal sehen kann was
bedeutet das eigentlich wenn ich das
mache und dass man als auch viel
einfacher machte leute zu verstehende
hey es gibt so viele öffentliche
vorlesungen universitäten da kann man
mal hingehen und reinschnuppern und eben
mal schauen event - überhaupt in so
einer vorlesung in dem fach oder sich
dann nachher und ich finds kontrolle ich
glaube das könnte und wie sich einfacher
machen aber ich glaube letztendlich ist
auch einfach ein bisschen die
lebenserfahrung hat die dann eben erst
später kommt und wenn man dann haben
einen schweren gang wechselt weil sich
eben doch dinge geändert haben dann ist
es glaube ich heute auch nicht mehr so
schlimm wie früher aber ich glaube es
gibt trotzdem noch viele eltern einem
ort die dann vielleicht sagen hey warum
dies dass das mein leben darf ein
bisschen mehr freiraum schafft menschen
dass sie das noch machen kann
wir sehen die eigentlich beide sozusagen
den punkt des sozialen umfeld und das
auch gegen einander vergleichen was
macht der was macht der spielt das noch
rolle bei der entscheidungsfindung hat
wie war das bei euch vielleicht
also wenn man sie nicht hat das ist
keine große rolle gespielt
ich wusste ich möchte das so machen das
war für mich einfach so der traum
und ja was meine freunde gemacht haben
das war halt so was eben zu denen
gepasst hat nur weil jetzt irgendwie
einige von ihnen zum beispiel lernt dann
am ende gewählt haben war es nicht so
dass ich gesagt hat okay das möchte ich
jetzt auch machen weil es hat einfach
nicht zu mir persönlich gepasst aber ich
bin schon sehr dankbar dass meine eltern
nie druck ausgeübt haben also für meine
eltern war schule immer so was das macht
halt entweder für sich selbst oder macht
es halt nicht also ich bin nicht für
gute noten belohnt worden und ich bin
nie für schlechte bestraft worden und
deswegen habe ich halt immer eben nur
dafür gearbeitet weil ich es halt wollte
und ich habe nie druck verspürt dass ich
eine entscheidung treffen muss dass ich
irgendwie medizin studiert jura 4 muss
oder irgendwie sowas ich wusste ich kann
halt machen was ich möchte und meine
eltern werden mich dabei unterstützen
super und es ist dann auch so weit
gegangen dass du an der cambridge
university studiert hat und jetzt wenn
das korrekt ist oder wenn das falsche
school.de mich bitte bist du aber auch
wieder zurück in deutschland und macht
den master wie wir sie das aus ist das
noch mal ein krasser unterschied
also ich weiß noch nicht wie der master
bis ich kann es nicht sagen weil ich bin
jetzt war ein geschrieben aber ich hab
noch nicht angefangen ersten meister
beginnt ja erst im oktober also kann ich
da es noch keinen vergleich ziehen ich
kann nur vergleichen wie es jetzt in
deutschland wird es knapp war
wesentlichen aussagen deutschland
gemacht haben
dann wirst wenn wir da noch mal
nachfragen aber wie genau du sprichst es
an wie ist der vergleich
also ich habe ein auto während mein
bachelorstudium gemacht und ich würde
sagen eine große unterschied war vor
allem die
ja wie viel kontakt mann hatte mit
professoren und allgemeiner fachkräften
in chemnitz ist da einfach die zahl
wesentlich kleiner von den studenten auf
die lehrer weil man ebenso
kleingruppenunterricht hat also da sitzt
man dann schnell mal zu zweit mit einem
professor dar und diskutiert daneben die
themen der vorlesung das ist jetzt
sowohl da nicht gewesen in deutschland
ich muss aber auch eltern dass ich nicht
sagen kann ob das wirklich überall in
england so wäre oder eben ob das jetzt
was ist was speziell in cambridge und
oxford so ist weil die eben diesen
kleinen unterricht ja auch immer
speziell anbieten kann ich sagen wie sie
jetzt an der englischen universität im
vergleich gewesen wäre
danke trotzdem dass du es mit uns
geteilt hast
was mir noch wichtig ist oder was uns
auch wichtig ist bei dieser frage wir
haben das natürlich im blick vielleicht
gibt es in ein und anderen bei euch dass
ich eben diese frage jetzt gerade stellt
was mache ich eigentlich und vielleicht
mögt ihr da ja mal so eine message geben
das war euer weg oder ein kleiner tipp
der dabei helfen kann und ja die message
dass man sich da vielleicht auch nicht
so von rund unter druck setzen lassen
muss klare
ich würde sagen probiere dich ausmacht
so viele praktika wie geht man wenn es
nur ein tag ist oder ein wochen
praktikum ist man findet er es heraus
was man für den rest seines lebens
machen will indem man mal in jeder
sparte reingeschnuppert hat und klar
einer uni kann man sich gerne angucken
also wie gesagt wir brauchen auch ärzte
und rechtsanwälte und alles andere was
man noch so studiert aber dass man
vielleicht auch mal ein praktikum
richtung handwerk macht und ein
praktikum richtung pflege weil nur wenn
man sich ausprobiert dann kann man
hinterher sagen okay das ist meins
ich leite die selbe frage nochmal weiter
anna-lena was wäre so deine message an
junge menschen die sich das gerade
fragen
also ich kann das was ja gesagt nun
schreiben und ich würde nur noch
hinzufügen lasst euch auch da von
niemandem reinreden weil letztendlich
ist es eure entscheidungen und ja
natürlich kann man auch berufe wechseln
und so weiter aber ein studium oder eine
ausbildung bereitet natürlich schon auf
gewissen weg vor und eröffnet euch ja
dann auch möglichkeiten in dem bereich
und macht deswegen etwas was für euch
das richtige ist nicht etwas wovon eure
eltern denken dass es das richtige ist
eure freunde oder sonstwer und andere
von ihr überzeugt dass er es machen
wollte
vielen dank euch beiden und bei youtube
und auch in unseren anderen plattformen
kommen auch ganz viele positive
kommentare für eure haltungen für euren
weg den wir gegangen seid da wird sich
sehr bedankt das leite ich euch gerne
weiter und bedanke mich auch sehr
herzlich dass ihr hier bei uns bei zdf
heute live dabei sein und über die frage
gesprochen habt studium oder eben doch
ausbildung ich glaube wir können
festhalten beide sind unterschiedlichen
weg gegangen aber am ende war er doch
individuell der beste
wir machen aber natürlich hier noch
weiter und schauen auch auf das thema
gibt es auch die chancengleichheit im
bereich ausbildung wir sehen da den
trend dass es immer richtung studium
geht gerade in deutschland und immer
weniger betriebe die ausbildungsplätze
tatsächlich besetzt bekommen ein
gängiger aspekt der dann im kopf auch
glaube ich herum schwirrt ist der aspekt
des verdienstes und womit kann man denn
mehr verdienen mit der ausbildung im
betrieb sich hocharbeiten oder doch der
akademische weg studium abschluss und
dann in akademische berufe gehen eine
antwort darauf hat alle steinfurt
wer die ausbildung zum meister oder
techniker hat der liegt im laufe seines
erwerbslebens finanziell erst einmal
leicht vor akademiker in erst mit 60
haben menschen mit hochschulabschluss
die nase vorn das sagt eine studie des
tübinger instituts für angewandte
wirtschaftsforschung von 2020 aber auch
ohne meistertitel sind die
verdienstmöglichkeiten mit einer
berufsausbildung gut sagt doktor regina
franke vom institut der deutschen
wirtschaft in köln was wir aber auch
ganz klar sehen dass auch in einer
anstellung also wenn ich einen ford
bildungsabschluss habe und in einem
unternehmen angestellt bin ich auch da
gute einkommen sondern auch
karriereperspektiven habe viel
führungsverantwortung übernehmen kann
und eben auch gute verdienstmöglichkeit
haben die durchaus vergleichbar sind mit
bestimmten akademischen
verdienstmöglichkeiten im direkten
vergleich stehen die ausbildungsberufe
zum teil sogar besser da so verdienen
bauleiter ohne studium mit
durchschnittlich 55 1737 euro rund 4000
euro mehr als architektin mit
bachelorabschluss
einstudierter finanzbuchhalter mit
43.000 206 euro ungefähr 6000 euro
weniger als eine bankkauffrau und ein
produktionsplaner mit 50.000 760 euro
durchschnittlichen lohn über 4600 euro
mehr als eine online marketing managerin
wofür man sich entscheidet ist
letztendlich also vor allem eine frage
der persönlichen neigung
absolut und die aktuelle neigung dass
zumindest die zahlen von heute die so
lässt sich vermuten zeigen in richtung
studium und weniger in richtung
ausbildung woran könnte das liegen das
vertiefen wir jetzt wieder und gehen so
ein bisschen in den forschungsbereich um
das auch so ein bisschen fundierter noch
anzugehen dazu vorstellig clemens
wieland von der bertelsmann stiftung der
ist jetzt bei uns hier im stream zu gast
schönen guten abend herr wieland schön
dass sie bei uns sind fragen sie wie
entscheidend glauben sie ist denn auch
dieser erste gedanke studium gleich mehr
geld bei vielen in der
entscheidungsfindung
zunächst guten abend herr hoch
ich glaube es ist keine gute idee sich
bei der berufswahl entscheidung von den
durchschnittseinkommen von bundesweiten
zahlen zu durchschnittseinkommen leiten
zu lassen und meine beiden vorrednerin
ihre interviewpartnerinnen die haben ja
auch recht eindrucksvoll dargelegt wie
wichtig das ist den eigenen neigungen zu
folgen und eigene erfahrungen zu sammeln
und darauf die entscheidung aufzubauen
und nicht darauf was das statistisch
vielleicht am ende des tages mal raus
springt ich kann das auch nur
unterstützen was die frau doktor flagge
gerade in dem interview gesagt hat gute
verdienstchancen gibt es grundsätzlich
in beiden bereichen gibt es in der
ausbildung und die gibt es im studium
man muss eben seine chancen nutzen und
dann aus dem weg den man eingeschlagen
hat möglichst viel machen aber wie
ordnen sie dann die zahlen von heute ein
dass doch betriebe sagen dass sie 43
prozent ihrer auszubildenden stellen
nicht besetzen können wenn sie
eigentlich auch in der forschung die
erkenntnis haben gute chancen gibt es
durchaus den beiden bereichen
darauf gibt es keine so einfache antwort
zunächst mal ist es so in den letzten
jahren ist ja die studierneigung also
die anzahl der studenten er gleich
geblieben die es nicht permanent
gestiegen was gesunken ist ist die
ausbildungs nachfrage also die zahl der
jugendlichen die eine ausbildung machen
möchten und das hat wiederum
unterschiedliche gründe ein ganz
wichtiger ist dass die möglichkeiten der
berufsorientierung gerade jetzt in den
corona zeiten so schwierig sich so
schwierig gestaltet haben also auch das
haben wir ja in den vorangegangenen
interviews so gehört wie wichtig das ist
praktika zu machen reinzuschnuppern
gespräche zu führen wir wissen aus
jugendbefragung wie wichtig gerade diese
praxis erfahrungen sind und die
gespräche mit lebendigen personen die
was über ihre erfahrungen berichten
können wenn das wegfällt was vielerorts
der fall war dann geht das stark zu
lasten der berufswahl entscheidung und
das trifft die ausbildung mehr als das
studium
der absolut jean-paul pawlowski fragt
bei youtube in welchen branchen
vielleicht haben sie dann überblick
besteht eigentlich alles ein mangel an
azubis
also grundsätzlich ist der mangel über
die branchen hinweg aber er ist sehr
unterschiedlich ausgeprägt also
besonders vor besonderen
besondere schwierigkeiten bei der
stellenbesetzung hat zum beispiel die
gastronomie das ernährungs mittel
handwerk reinigungsgewerbe
und das liegt aber eben auch daran dass
das bereiche sind die bei den
jugendlichen nicht so attraktiv sind wie
andere da gibt es auch höhere
abbruchquoten während der ausbildung
dass die verteilung ist sehr ungleich
also es gibt branchen da sind über die
hälfte der azubi stellen nicht besetzt
und es gibt branchen die haben wenig
probleme damit noch nachwuchs zu finden
nicht nur diese verteilung ist manchmal
ungleich manchmal oder auch manchmal
sehr oft sind auch die chancen ungleich
auch in deutschland herr wieland da
kommt auch eine frage zur ein von saint
bei youtube wie hoch ist der
studierenden anteil aus familien mit
bildungsfernem hintergrund
und wie sieht es da auch bei den
ausbildungen aus wie ist da der
vergleich
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt ich
kann nicht die zahl präsentieren aber
ich kann sagen das ist leider nach wie
vor so ist das in deutschland die der
bildungsstand der eltern und sehr
maßgeblichen 1 das darauf hat was dann
auch die jugendlichen für einen
bildungsweg einschlagen hat vielleicht
auch damit zu tun also 70 prozent der
jugendlichen sagen dass eltern die
wichtigsten berater bei der berufswahl
entscheidung sind und dass auch das kam
vorhin schon zur sprache eltern eben oft
sagen ja du sollst studieren du sollst
den senat einen besseren abschluss
machen oder den bestmöglichen und wenn
die eltern das selbst selbst studiert
haben dann erst recht
und hinzu kommt noch dass die
berufsorientierung die in der schule
angeboten wird eben auch das haben wir
gehört vielfach an den gymnasien immer
noch sehr stark und einseitig nur auf
studienmöglichkeiten hin orientiert und
die welt der ausbildungsberufe die für
den einen oder anderen eben eine genauso
geeignete oder noch viel geeignetere
wäre zu kurz kommt
eine weitere frage die ich ihn gerne
weiterleite von daniel wolf auch bei
youtube und das ist so eine stimmt dass
frage in deutschland studieren er
weniger leute im vergleich zu anderen
entwickelten industrieländer fragt sich
daniel wolf ob das so ist steht können
sie das bestätigen
auch das ist eine interessante
beobachtung also die die oecd die hat
lang hin bemängelt dass die studierquote
in deutschland zu gering wäre im
internationalen vergleich das sagt sie
mittlerweile nicht mehr weil man auch
dort erkannt hat dass die duale
berufsausbildung oder die
berufsausbildung insgesamt es gibt ja
auch eine vollzeit schulische
berufsausbildung einen ganz großen
stellenwert hat um ein wirtschaftssystem
ein gut funktionierendes
wirtschaftssystem so wie es das deutsche
jahr immer noch ist am laufen zu halten
und die hohen studieren einigungen in
anderen ländern die liegen eben auch
daran dass die gar keine so attraktiven
berufsausbildungssystem haben duale
ausbildungssystem also diese kopplung
von theorie und praxis von betrieb und
berufsschule
die gibt es nur in wenigen ländern die
haben wir noch in österreich in der
schweiz in dänemark und ansatzweise
vielleicht noch in ein paar anderen
ländern aber die anderen da dominiert
das studium und wer da eine berufliche
ausbildung macht er ist also eigentlich
nicht so ganz ernst zu nehmen sage ich
jetzt mal etwas flapsig
sie haben auch angesprochen es war auch
immer thema im stream bei uns das thema
klischees gibt es glaube ich auf beiden
seiten und dazu haben wir auch eine user
frage von zu viel natur gibt
gallensteine mittlerweile wird gesagt
das ist das zitat des users macht ein
studium bloß keine ausbildung der eine
ausbildung die gilt als abstieg warum
ist das vielleicht so
können sie da irgendwie eine antwort
liefern ist das so ein bisschen was
verankertes im kopf
das mag sein aber das sind einfach
veraltete bilder also wir hatten wenn
sie ein paar jahrzehnte zurückgehen da
gab es ja noch ganz klar zwei säulen da
gab es die berufliche bildung und die
hat eben er so für die für die praktisch
begabten möglichkeiten gibt geboten und
dann gab es die akademische bildung die
war für eine relativ kleine in
anführungszeichen elite gedacht das hat
sich ja ganz stark geändert die zahlen
wurden angesprochen mittlerweile gibt es
mehr studierende jedes jahr als du
welche die in die duale ausbildung gehen
und die grenzen verschwimmen und auch
die anspruchsniveau verein an sich es
ist ja eben nicht mehr so dass ein
handwerker heute nur mit schraubenzieher
säge ich weiß nicht was unterwegs ist
sondern das sind ja zum teil hoch
anspruchsvolle und auch digitalisierte
automatisierte techniken wollen wurde
also als ein beispiel dieser kran
angesprochen der ist ja anders zu
bedienen als wenn man eben mit den
schweren lasten die treppe hoch gehen
muss und von daher war es eigentlich
wünschenswert wäre es wenn berufliche
bildung und akademischer bildung nicht
mehr so gegeneinander ausgespielt würden
sondern wenn man die übergänge ein
bisschen fließender gestalten könnte es
gibt tolle karriere optionen über die
berufsausbildung es gibt tolle karriere
optionen über das studium und es gibt
auch wege die dazwischen laufen nur sind
die oft zu wenig bekannt also wir halten
fest vielleicht er vergleicht das
gegeneinander ausspielen das vielleicht
kein sinnvolles ziel mit oder keinen
sinnvollen lösungsansatz um die
situation zu verbessern dann sind wir
doch auch schon bei weiteren vielleicht
besseren konstruktiven vorschlägen
herbie land wie könnte man vorgehen um
diese situation um die zahlen die heute
herausgekommen sind für bildungs
betriebe zu verbessern
zunächst mal ein bereich ist der es geht
ja bei den sinkenden zahlen den
sinkenden ausbildungszahlen nicht wird
um die konkurrenz zwischen ausbildung
und studium sondern es geht auch darum
dass viele jugendliche sich vermutlich
in den auch gerade in den letzten jahren
in der pandemie zeit gar nicht erst
beworben haben weil sie verunsichert
waren weil sie in längeren schulbesuch
vorgezogen haben oder einfach abgetaucht
sind
meines erachtens geht es schon auch
darum dass es uns gelingen muss auch
jugendliche mit niedriger schulbildung
die eben am ausbildungsmarkt auch oft
außen vor bleiben trotz der vielen
unbesetzten ausbildungsplätze besser und
verstärkt in ausbildung zu integrieren
wir haben einerseits über 60.000
unbesetzte ausbildungsplätze das ist für
die wirtschaft katastrophal wir haben
aber auch über 60.000 jugendliche jedes
jahr die mehr oder weniger leer ausgehen
entweder weise in eine so genannte
alternative in eine maßnahme etwas
anderes einmünden aber eigentlich lieber
eine ausbildung machen würden oder weil
sie wirklich leer ausgehen und dann auf
der straße stehen und
der fachmann nennt das passus probleme
das heißt wir haben dieses dieses
ungewöhnliche paradoxe phänomen dass wir
gleichzeitig viele unbesetzte
ausbildungsplätze haben gleichzeitig
aber auch viele jugendliche die leer
ausgehen und dafür müssen wir lösungen
finden ein vorschlag der von ihnen auch
kommuniziert wurde von der bertelsmann
stiftung und wo sich außerdem daran
forschen das ist der punkt
ausbildungsgarantie funktioniert
offenbar wohl schon in österreich
vielleicht fernsehens auf was ist das
genau und wie könnte oder könnte das
auch eine möglichkeit sein die man auf
deutschland übertragen kann und das
würde dann was bringt
in österreich ist es so dass jugendliche
unter 25 jahren die versucht haben einen
ausbildungsplatz im dualen
ausbildungssystem zu finden und die da
gescheitert sind trotz wiederholter
bewerbungs bemühungen dass die anspruch
haben auf einen sogenannten außer
betrieblichen ausbildungsplatz das ist
eine ausbildung die bei einem
bildungsträger statt endet
das finde ich ein sehr intelligentes und
sinnvolles konstrukt wenn man es richtig
macht und richtig angeht und in
österreich ist es zum beispiel so erst
wird in einer zehn wochen dauernden
einstiegsphase versucht den jugendlichen
doch erstmal noch in den regulären
ausbildungsmarkt zu vermitteln das ist
ja immer der königsweg ausbildung im
betrieb nur wenn das nicht gelingt dann
bekommt er eben diesen einstieg in die
sogenannte außerbetriebliche ausbildung
aber das ist dann auch kein
freifahrschein und auch nicht wie
kritiker gerne sagen eine
ausbildungsgarantie auf wunschberufe gar
nicht wenn man er bekommt einen einstieg
zunächst mal auf ein jahr befristet und
dann wird weiterhin versucht den in
einem in die betriebliche ausbildung zu
vermitteln und das gelingt auch häufig
in österreich und davon profitieren dann
eigentlich beide seiten die betriebe
bekommen jugendliche die schon
vorqualifiziert sind vielleicht auch
schon etwas an das betriebliche leben
gewöhnt sind und die jugendlichen
bekommen eine einstiegschance die sie
davor nicht hatten also ein
konstruktiver ansatz den uns clemens
wieland von der bertelsmann-stiftung
hier zum schluss unsere streams noch mal
mit auf den weg gibt vielleicht ja eine
maßnahme die angegangen wird vielen dank
herr wieland für ihre einschätzungen zu
dem thema ausbildung oder studium
herzlichen dank und noch einen schönen
abend dann sie vielen dank für das
gespräch herr hoch
vielen dank euch auch fürs zuschauen wir
hoffen dass die die vielleicht hiermit
zugeschaut haben vielleicht ein paar
tipps und vielleicht auch ein gutes
gefühl bekommen haben wenn sie sich
gerade die entscheidung stellen zwischen
studium und ausbildung wir haben auch
darauf geschaut war es sind gründe dafür
warum betriebe gerade sagen wir können
unsere auszubildenden stellen nicht
besetzen und sind hinten raus da auch
nochmal mit einer konstruktiven idee mit
der ausbildungsgarantie rausgegangen
vielen dank an euch fürs zuschauen und
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal auch wieder dabei sein